by the end of bloodshot rate garrison is
finally starting to piece together his
past his real past who was Ray before he
became bloodshot how did he die in the
first place and what's this all building
to anyway we've got the answers well
most of them anyway
in bloodshot most of what we learn about
ray garrison simply isn't true
the Darien hostage rescue that opens the
film as a fabricated hero module
designed to give him confidence his
relationship with Jeana ended five years
ago she wasn't killed she wasn't even
his wife so by the end of the movie what
do we know about him well going off a
few stray lines of dialogue we can
safely say that ray really was part of
the military Gina the real one notes
that ray kept leaving on classified
missions he might have come home every
time but Gina couldn't deal with him
leaving in the first place that's why
their relationship ended we also know
that Ray has a keen sense of justice a
righteous temper and doesn't let go of a
grudge
bloodshot soul pieces which is summed up
at the end of the movie is that memories
don't make the man actions do as such
there's no reason to look backwards the
specifics of Ray's pass might remain a
mystery but it doesn't matter he's
moving forward regardless for such a
brutal story bloodshot has a
surprisingly uplifting ending the bad
guys are dead Gina is safe and has moved
on flood shots biggest limitation the
way his nanites run out of power forcing
him to stop and recharge has been
removed now it's just rag Katie Wilford
Wiggins their shared trailer and a
beautiful Oceanside paradise it's
perfect
maybe a little too perfect our st's
entire scheme hinged on its ability to
manipulate Ray's reality who's to say
they're not doing it again
that's what Wilfred wonders right before
the film smash cuts to the credits is
what Katie implies when she says that
their tropical surroundings are a dream
Wilfred has a new very different set of
clothes the final scenes warm lights and
bright color palette recall ray and
Gina's trip to Italy which was also a
fantasy invented by rst now this isn't
inception bloodshot isn't a particularly
subtle movie and we're probably supposed
to take everything we see at face value
still if Sony wanted to open a bloodshot
sequel by revealing that this happy
ending wasn't so happy after all it
wouldn't be a surprise the groundwork
has already been laid what do you think
is really
sometimes angling for all intents and
purposes bloodshot is married
it's the fictional death of his fake
wife Gina that's first blood shot into
action without that connection false as
it might be RS t's whole plan for
manipulating Rea falls apart and yet if
you thought you picked up on some sexual
tension between Rhea and Katie in the
film's final scene you're not alone
Katie totally has the hots for Ray and
it seems like ray is starting to feel
the same way because of the movie's
premise Katie could fall in love with
ray over time but not the other way
around their romance had to take an
unusual form as director Dave Wilson
told us because of bloodshot's total
memory loss this could never be a
conventional love relationship I wanted
a love story that the audience didn't
see coming of course the movie drops
plenty of hints that bloodshot and Katie
you're going to end up as an item when a
devastated ray learns that nobody came
to collect his body
Katie reassures him that there's someone
out there who loves him at the time
you're supposed to think Katie is
referring to Gina who is still alive but
no she's talking about herself while the
film's ending doesn't reveal bloodshot's
identity his comics do well kind of
fittingly bloodshot's backstory has been
rebooted in retcon many times since the
characters 1992 debut and it's hard to
pin down an exact origin story ironic
right at least poor ray comes by it
honestly in the first volume of
bloodshot which was originally written
by Kevin Van Hook and drawn by Don
Perlin the titular hero was revealed to
be a violent mobster named Angelo
mortally ruthless and driven more Talley
was a rising star in don gino canalis
crime family until Kennelly learned that
more Tolly was cheating on his fiancee
who just happened to be canalis daughter
Canelli framed more Talley for a violent
crime for Seymour Talley into witness
protection where he was killed by a
corrupt FBI agent rising spirits got its
hands on him shortly thereafter the name
ray garrison didn't enter blood shot
cannon until vol 2 launched in 1997 as
one of bloodshot's other alternate
identities over the years he's had
plenty of others these days bloodshot
assumes that ray is his real personality
and that Angelo was a cover he adopted
while on a classified mission although
he doesn't know for sure at this rate he
never will
here's the thing though the cinematic
bloodshot could still go the angelo
mortal ear out assuming that the movie
gets a sequel according to former
Valiants Entertainment CEO Dinesh
Hasani early drafts of the bloodshot
script leaned heavily into the mafia
angle and the film's lack of definite
answers leaves room for mortality to
appear in the sequel in fact we already
have one hint that bloodshot sending is
a little deceptive and that Rey or
whoever he actually is isn't exactly the
stand-up guy the finale makes him out to
be during one a bloodshot's action
scenes dr. Harding taunts Rey by noting
that the soldier signed up from the
military service because he enjoys
violence Rey protests but the evidence
is all there on the screen let's face it
hijacking an airplane and killing half a
dozen people isn't exactly a normal
response to trauma you know nothing
about men like me it's an interesting
concept and one that could make for an
interesting angle in a sequel by the end
of the movie bloodshot says he's done
looking backwards but learning that he
was more of a villain that a hero pre
transformation could make him change his
mind of all the different iterations of
bloodshot the film draws the most
heavily on the 2012 reboot which really
played up the entire false memories and
mind control angles in that story
bloodshot learns that he's being
manipulated barely early on and takes
the war to rising spirit fairly quickly
that's where the movie ends but a
bloodshot sequel continues down that
path then we know exactly where this
story is going in the comics bloodshot
learns he's not project rising spirits
only victim over the years the project
has also been kidnapping children with
superpowers who are known as harbingers
by making bloodshot think that the kids
are in danger a rising spirit has been
reliant on the Super Soldier to round up
the powerful little tykes bloodshot
drops the kids off at the project's labs
where they're caged and experimented on
then he has his memory wiped before he
sets off for the next batch naturally
bloodshot freeze the kids when he learns
what's going on but dropping two dozen
superpower children into the real world
without any warning has big
repercussions in the comics that led to
a massive crossover event called
Harbinger warps in theaters it could
lead to a similar Avenger style event if
one major obstacle doesn't get in the
way
originally harbinger Wars was valiant in
Sony's endgame in 2015 The Hollywood
Reporter confirmed that bloodshot then
scheduled for 2017 release with John
waste chats the hell ski and david
leitch set to direct was going to be the
first entry in Valiants big screen
superhero universe Harbinger would be
the second each movie would get a sequel
and then the two franchises would
crossover for the
Wars event however in 2019 the Harbinger
movie moved from Sony to Paramount with
the characters now at two separate
companies a crossover seems increasingly
unlikely it could still happen of course
Sony itself has already teamed up with
Marvel Studios to bring spider-man into
the MCU although that relationship has
been relatively complicated the chances
aren't great when we ask bloodshot
director Dave Wilson about a potential
sequel he was quick to list all the
places a larger bloodshot universe could
go there are groups and characters that
love from blood squirt to blood hounds a
hardcore there is enough material out
there in the valiant universe to make
any number of films you want
tellingly though while those characters
do interact with the larger valiant
universe they're primarily bloodshot
spin-offs at this point in time a larger
valiant series with bloodshot at the
center seems like a fairly dicey
proposition check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]